THEY'RE IN THE BALLOT BUSINESS
NOW.
THANK YOU BOTH.
VERY INSIGHTFUL.
WE TURN TO A TROUBLING STORY OUT
OF DETROIT WHERE LEGENDARY
SURGEON AND FORMER PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE DR. BEN CARSON HAD HIS
NAME REMOVED FROM A PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOL AFTER A RESENT VOTE BY A
FAR LEFT SCHOOL BOARD.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT SAID IN PART
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSING CONCERNS REGARDING
HOW UNDER EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
THE SCHOOL'S NAME WAS CHANGED TO
BEN CARSON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
WAS IMPOSED GOVERNANCE, A
STRUCTURE THAT DID NOT REPRESENT
THE VOICES OF DETROITERS OR
THEIR VOTE.
THEY ADDED, QUOTE, TO THE
CONCERN REGARDING HOW THE NAME
WAS CHANGED WAS THE FACT THAT
MANY PEOPLE IN DETROIT FELT THAT
DR. BEN CARSON'S POLITICAL
POSITIONS AND DECISIONS AS A
POLICY MAKER DID NOT REFLECT
DETROITERS AND THEREFORE A
SCHOOL SHOULD NOT BE NAMED AFTER
HIM.
BACK IN 2018, BY THE WAY, THE
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER LEADING THE
CHARGE TOLD "THE WASHINGTON
POST," QUOTE, IT'S SYNONYMOUS AS
HAVING TRUMP'S NAME ON OUR
SCHOOL IN BLACK FACE.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
DR. CARSON IS AN INSPIRATION TO
SO MANY, HAS AN OUTSTANDING
RECORD OF ACCOMPLISHMENT INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE OF THE HOSPITAL HE
WORKED IN.
SAVED MANY LIVES IN THE COURSE
OF HIS CAREER.
HE SHOULD BE PRAISED AND
CELEBRATED, NOT SMEARED AND
SLANDERED.
JUST BECAUSE HE HAPPENS TO BE A
REPUBLICAN.
AND BY THE WAY, IN A NEW PIECE
FOR FOX NEWS, 55 INDIVIDUALS
THAT WORKED FOR DR. CARSON
WROTE, THE DR. CARSON IS THE
EPITOME OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
ONLY IN OUR COUNTRY COULD A POOR
BOY FROM THE INNER CITY GROW UP
TO BE A WORLD RENOWN SURGEON,
PRESIDENTIA
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE, AND
HOUSING SECRETARY.
TO THE FAR LEFT LUNATICS, ONLY
ONE THING MATTERS, WHETHER OR
NOT YOU HAVE A D NEXT TO YOUR
NAME.
DR. BEN CARSON JOINS ME.
I THINK WHAT BOTHERS ME MOST
ABOUT THIS, NUMBER ONE, I KNOW
YOU AND AM FRIENDS WITH YOU.
NO. 2, SYNONYMOUS WITH HAVING
TRUMP'S NAME ON OUR SCHOOL IN
BLACK FACE.
DR. CARSON?
NOBODY SHOULD HAVE TO PUT UP
WITH THAT?
>> IT'S VERY SAD THAT WE'VE
REACHED A POINT WHERE POLITICAL
IDEOLOGY TRUMPS THE WHOLE
PURPOSE OF AN EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION.
WE SEE THIS WOKENESS SPREADING
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY TO THE
DESTRUCTION OF OUR COMMUNITY.
HOW DOES IT DO ANY GOOD FOR US
TO DEMONIZE PEOPLE WITH WHOM WE
DISAGREE.
AND TO TEACH THAT TO OUR
CHILDREN AT A TIME WHEN THE MATH
SCORES ARE DOWN, THE READING
SCORES ARE DOWN, ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE IS DOWN.
AND MANY OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND HIGH SCHOOLS, PEOPLE ARE
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL ARE
FUNCTIONALLY ILLITERATE.
THEY CAN'T FILL OUT AN
APPLICATION OR THE DIRECTIONS IN
THE PRODUCT THAT THEY BUY.
SOMETIMES THEY'RE LEFT IN A
SITUATION WHERE IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO MAKE A
LIVING.
WE'RE FAILING THEM BY PUSHING
THIS IDEOLOGY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS AT
AMERICAN CORNERSTONE, WE HAVE
PUSHED THE LITTLE PATRIOTS
PROGRAM, TEACHING CHILDREN WHAT
THEY SHOULD KNOW ABOUT THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE NATION IS,
WHAT OUR HISTORY IS.
THE GOOD, THE BAD, THE UGLY.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT OBJECTIVELY,
THERE'S A LOT MORE GOOD THAN
THERE IS BAD AND UGLY.
WE NEED TO TEACH THAT TO OUR
CHILDREN AND THOSE PRINCIPLES
AND LITTLEPATRIOTSLEARNING.COM,
A FREE PROGRAM BECAUSE WE GET
PEOPLE TO UNDERWRITE IT, WE WANT
TO CHANGE THIS WHOLE NARRATIVE
AND WE NEED AN INDOCKETRY
NATION -- AN INOCULATION TO TIN
DOCKETRY NATION.
THAT'S WHY WE CREATED THAT
PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE FUND, WE PUT IN 250
READING ROOMS THROUGHOUT THE
NATION WHERE KIDS COME HOME WITH
FEW BOOKS, GO TO SCHOOLS WITH
LITTLE BUDGETS FOR LIBRARIES,
THEY DON'T BECOME READERS.
IF YOU CAN BECOME A PROFICIENT
READER AT GRADE 3, IT CHANGES
THE TRAJECTORY OF YOUR LIFE.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
>> HANNITY: THAT'S THE STORY OF
YOUR LIFE AND MOM FORCING YOU TO
READ AND NOT HANG OUT WITH KIDS
IN THE STREET AND STAY INSIDE
AND DO YOUR WORK AND IT CHANGED
YOUR LIFE, TRANSFORMED YOUR
LIFE.
WHAT YOUR MOM DID FOR YOU WILL
WORK FOR ANY C